ciao ragazzi benvenuti in questo
nuovissimo video mi avete chiesto dopo
il video degli out di natale che perde
un sacco mi avete chiesto anche il video
sugli outfit per capodanno chiaramente
perché se ci banda in paranoia lauzi di
natale quello di capodanno
perico insomma vi starete chiedendo
perché sono è già ma perché volevo
immedesimarmi in voi che in questo
momento sarete pigiamo a causa che
frugando tra madio per capire che
diavolo mettere a capodanno
quindi la prima cosa che vi consiglio di
fare sicuramente di truccarvi un po e
pettinari somma a fare proprio le prove
generali diciamoci la verità come fosse
un saggio di danza quindi trucco
parrucco e sicuramente qualsiasi vestito
che proverete vi starà meglio di con la7
magari struccate appena sveglie la
veglia truffati ma questo già lo
sapevate
quindi partiamo subito ma aspettate un
attimo perché io devo salutare 3d voi
saluto milena tano e mezzago e cinesina
con lewis e se volete farvi saltare nel
prossimo video ricordatevi seguire le
istruzioni che vi lasciano qui alla fine
del giglio
ma passiamo subito agli outfit per
capodanno e anti sisma e star zitto per
capodanno
allora proprio come ho fatto per il
video sugli altri di natale anche questa
volta divide role of it a gruppi con i
loro hashtag d'appartenenza
questo chiaramente appartiene a tinelli
i sempreverdi di lieve green di normale
di una ragazza ecco il no manca mai
vestito nero a maggior ragione si sballa
di un tubino che è vero ma le abbiamo
tutte quindi quello che potrei
consigliare se proprio non riuscite a
fare a meno deposto tubino nero o non
riuscite a trovare delle alternative e
uscite sempre col nero lasciatevi anche
in nero per capodanno magari arricchito
con un particolare tipo degli orecchini
proprio belli esagerati
e la borsetta definita non lancia
trovato subito a prendere la pochette i
na'vi interrata ecco questo penso che
sia un buon compromesso per essere
sempre con l'osso tubino nero di amato
che mettete sempre però per capodanno
renderlo un po più a riciclare se vi
state chiedendo come fatto passare dai
capelli che avevo inizio dei video a
questo ci non vuol dire che vi siete
perse il video sulle acconciature le
quattro acconciature per le feste
vi metto il link qui di iscrizione hanno
però vedere e copiate vi subito questa
pettinatura che io trovo veramente toppa
d'oro e a proposito di neri a proposito
di sobrietà a proposito di marina e l'ho
comprato da poco e non avevo ancora
provato fino adesso lo trovo veramente
fantastico molto esagerato però perché
hanno secondo me ci sta ci sono liti
lavorando quando 20 quindi se che godano
volete si essere sexy ma anche a dare a
fare una rapina a qualche banca stile
eva kent potete mettere questa e io ad
ora ma siamo al secondo è che i rossi
c'erano anche a natale ci sono anche a
capodanno perché il rosso diciamo fa
subito festa
questo vestito tra l'altro fa subito a
capodanno perché diciamo è bello strong
con questo corpetto non indifferente
mi sento molto la regina di cuori ma
vediamo subito che il secondo vestito
rosso
allora hanno preso da poco ed era la
prima volta che me lo provavo e edoardo
testimone abbia detto ho trovato il
vestito mettono a votare non mi sa che
ho quasi deciso per lui perche e cobas
fate per parte dei rossi ma è veramente
molto
come dire spanish e niente molto comoda
tra l'altro si può anche ballare guarda
per un capodanno pieno di fascino verso
gli anche tu con il tutto ong scollato
ma non è capodanno senza hyatt e quindi
l'ashtag e qualità e abbiamo il panetta
toro che avrete visto in un po di video
miei 1 anche molto recente e questo
vestito una storia perché vi devo
raccontare le ho preso per i miei 18
anni era più largo e più lungo io ero
qualche cosa in più ai tempi lo feci
tagliare perché lo voglio più corto
dimagrendo l'ho fatto anche insomma
stringe cioè un altro vestito rispetto
comprato però resistente perché sono
anni che continua a essere comunque un
bel vestito molto paillé toso e passiamo
a le palette ma tir altro colore
e a proposito di paillettes una paghetta
insomma molto stilosa perché questo
modello sembra quasi anni 80 anche molto
ispirato agli anni 80 e subito dancing
queen anni 80
so che questo per alcuni video stiamo
appunto dicendo che non ho mai messo per
uscire ci hai usato solo per shooting
per video
devo trovare una sera da milano dove
poterlo mettere quindi si accettano
consigli
detto questo passiamo al prossimo ma
passiamo un must per marina che l'oro
chiaramente ormai lo sapete questo
vestito di stampo l'aretino perché lì un
po di anni fa lo utilizzano per un
capodanno molto speciale molto bene ho
passato con la mamma a dubai e niente lo
provo molto stile greco molto versaci ma
non eri versaci e non mi conte che
marcare comunque ho parlato anche da
senza bonus ma fa un figurone quindi per
un capodanno super elegante super chic
un bell'abito lungo oro e si vola
e a proposito di oro non poteva mancare
un abbinamento oro nero come sempre c'è
questa pace cena tra l'altro che è di
mia mamma vinto negli anni 80 che oro
nero quindi top non si sa niente ma i
top e c'è questo movimento appunto di
body nero molto scollato dietro tutta la
schiena scoperta e vanta col oro quindi
oro nero molto poco sobrio molto carico
molto marina e per la donna aggressiva
che non deve chiedere mai questo
l'affitto giusto sotto con la tela
versace sopra rock and roll
l'ho intitolato l'aggressivo mano trova
molto top per un capodanno
indimenticabile soprattutto molto molto
borchiato siamo giunti al termine anche
di questo video sugli ospiti capodanno
spero tra quelli di natale e quella di
favola di avermi aiutato a trovare gli
outfit giusti per queste feste
fatemi sapere quali questi outfit avete
preferito quale non mettere ste marie
quale vi piacerebbe mettere e
soprattutto se avete già scelto o meno
il vostro outfit per la serata di
capodanno
vi ricordo che se volete essere salutati
del mio prossimo video non dovete far
altro che seguire questi piccoli step
seguirmi su instagram scrivermi un bel
direct con scritto ciao mi chiamo e il
vostro nome
mi sono tristi per favore e il terzo è
guardare il prossimo video per vedere se
siete tra i fortunati che salutano se
hai creduto il video mette di un bel
laiche lasciatevi un commentino se non
l'avete ancora fatto
cosa aspettate iscrivetevi al mio
fantasmagorico canale e seguitemi su
tutti gli altri social facebook
instagram e musicali io vi mando ma ciò
detto va d'oro e waiting for capodanno